on patrol in a primeval forest in Poland
two environmental activists are
inspecting the trees in brv Asia and
National Park
Augustin Niko's and his friend Wojcik
are looking at both healthy and diseased
trees all this is natural forest growth
it's very old more than 170 years this
forest wasn't really ever managed by
humans it's followed the rules of nature
over the course of thousands of years
decaying trees are occupied by thousands
of birds insects and other creatures
this is Europe's last ancient forest and
a unesco world heritage site this
woodland is vitally important and
invaluable it is the only place I will
be able to show my children what
primeval forest looks like that's why I
want to protect it a little further on
there are deep furrows in the forest
floor huge harvesters were deployed here
and a clearing created in the middle of
the forest more than a hundred hectares
were cleared the devastation is pretty
well advanced as you can see here the
forest authorities say the clear cutting
is necessary to combat a bark beetle
infestation knocking quotas were tripled
last year there's some dispute about
where exactly trees can be felled a
group of environmental advocates living
in this house are dedicated to
protecting the forest for months they
have been staging actions to thwart
logging efforts there have been some
tense clashes
activists sitting on the machines were
often removed by force it was pretty
dangerous I tied myself to the frame of
a harvester and one of the guards
climbed up and stood there for about an
hour talking to us there was less and
less space and I was afraid I'd slip off
they turned me over in my stomach
there's a steady stream of young people
coming and going to help with the
protests they stay as long as they can
protecting the forest as their mission
the forest is dying and has been for a
while
but there's so much logging that it
can't recover the politicians aren't
thinking about the future forest rangers
say the trees are being cut down to
protect the forest otherwise the bark
beetles will irreversibly damage the fur
population so the diseased trees must be
removed this area posed a danger to
people visiting the forest because trees
were falling over driven that's why
trees along the path were cleared the
forester says the forest will renew
itself the logs are stacked at the side
of the path the forest to deny is that
profit is the real motivation for the
logging we earned some money with it we
are state property and sure the state
receives revenue but only small amounts
say God's Pia let's key says this
interference protects the forest the
activists see things differently they
want to prevent all interference with
nature and they condemn the fact that
100 year old trees are being felled this
marking says the trees are over 100
years old the European Court of Justice
has ruled that it's illegal to cut down
in
furs like this opinion in the village of
Bao VA Jia is divided some are for
removing the trees others say leave the
forest alone it's ok to clear the forest
otherwise we have to get our wood from
far away it's better than letting it rot
[Music]
where are they chopping down trees and
destroying our ancient forests Michigan
coal I was born here and I'm against it
the paymo nature conservationists locals
and forest rangers each has their own
idea about how best to serve the forest
of bao via the two environmental
activists are shocked to see felled
trees in Europe's last primeval forest
and they will continue to fight to
protect it they believe this polish
forest can contribute to fighting
climate change